je pense qu'il faut aussi aider la
classe moyenne donc on a aidé les moins
riches si on veut mais il faut aussi
aider la classe moyenne puis on pense
qu'on est capable avec la situation
actuelle des finances publiques à la
fois de donner un répit du côté des
impôts donc de remettre d'argent dans le
portefeuille des Québécois incluant la
classe moyenne et continuer de mieux
financer des services entre autres en
éducation en santé
voilà François Legault qui nous donnait
un petit avant-goût du budget du Québec
qui sera dévoilé mardi préparez ce
budget là c'est une tâche colossale
ministre des Finances doit faire un tour
d'horizon complet des besoins de la
population oublier aucune des priorités
du Premier ministre contenter ses
collègues au cabinet et tout ça en
faisant des prévisions économiques les
plus justes possibles alors pour nous
parler des coulisses de cet exercice
Philippe Goujon il est économiste
directeur de la ferme d'analyse
stratégique apeco ancien directeur du
cabinet du ministre des Finances
girables bonsoir bonsoir vous le
connaissez bien Monsieur Girard vous
avez fait plusieurs budget avec lui donc
vous allez pouvoir nous en dire un peu
plus sur cette journée d'abord
évidemment quand on présente un budget
c'est disséquer analyser à la phrase
près par les médias les économistes les
entreprises milieu d'affaires etc est-ce
que c'est une journée que le ministre
Girard aime ou il l'appréhende un peu
des deux je dirais honnêtement c'est une
journée qui commence en souriant qui
continue un peu dans le stress parce que
les médias posent beaucoup de questions
il une tournée médiatique importante il
y a beaucoup d'informations à véhiculer
à connaître faut pas se tromper mais
comme je disais ministre du plaisir au
début de la journée au travail la
journée donc je dirais qu'en globalement
il content de sa journée puis de ce
moment-là finalement montrer tout ce que
il y a travaillé pendant un mois deux
mois et demi oui c'est ça bon évidemment
pour mardi en particulier pour cette
édition là du budget 2023 2024 on
s'attend en tout cas s'il y a pas de
baisse d'impôts on sera très très
surpris parce que ça a été extrêmement
télégraphié par le gouvernement depuis
des mois maintenant même si les grandes
centrales syndicales ont fait des mises
en garde on demandait au ministre Girard
il y a quelques semaines à peine de pas
aller de l'avant avec cette idée là il
était trop tard je présume on va voir ça
dans le budget
je serais extrêmement surpris le Premier
ministre comme vous l'extrait vous venez
de montrer l'a dit c'était l'engagement
principal de la carrière dans la
campagne électorale s'il y avait pas
fait ça c'est comme si admettons que
c'est au pouvoir il faisait rien à
l'environnement c'est c'est a été
contre-intuitif puis c'est donc c'est
certain que il va y avoir un prochain
budget puis effectivement c'est sûr que
demander à au début mars de ne pas faire
un geste comment c'est un pétard la
majorité des arbitrages sont faites à
peu près en mois de février avec le
Premier ministre donc peut-être que mars
un peu tard mais d'autres c'était
prononçables avant déjà ouais parce que
justement il y a toute une série de
consultations pré budgétaires ça se fait
en annonce ça commence même parfois en
janvier est-ce que ça sert à quelque
chose est-ce que le ministre vraiment à
l'oreille tendu vers les recommandations
les demandes qui lui sont faites dans
ces consultations là écoute toujours
c'est un moment important quand même une
consultation parce que c'est un moment
pour le ministre des Finances de
comprendre ce que les gens leur priorité
leurs c'est quoi qui les affecte c'est
quoi comment on peut les aider
malheureusement en politique on fait un
peu dans une bulle on vit un peu détaché
puis c'est quand même un moment de pour
s'assurer qu'on comprend bien tous les
enjeux qui sont et le ministre des
Finances il dit souvent il aime
travailler pour l'ensemble des Québécois
pas juste ce élu tous les Québécois donc
il écoute beaucoup à ce moment-là puis
ça fait une différence à plusieurs
reprises même dans ces consultations là
et dans les semaines qui précèdent le
budget on voit souvent des organisations
des syndicats des milieux d'affaires
faire ce qu'on appelle une liste
d'épicerie carrément on fait une liste
de demandes c'est quoi le secret pour
convaincre le mérinistre Girard que
c'est sa proposition sa clientèle qui
est la plus importante et qu'il faut
répondre à ses besoins-là je dirais la
première c'est pas faire une liste
justement c'est d'être concis c'est
d'être plus concis d'arriver avec une
deux ou trois priorités des demandes qui
sont bien chiffrées qui sont bien
démontrés il faut que les personnes
démontrent au ministre clairement c'est
quoi l'enjeu comment y répondre souvent
j'ai souvent vu moi une demande pour la
main d'oeuvre j'en veux vous aider pour
la méthode mais comment la solution à
vie rarement proposé puis le ministre
des Finances il veut trouver des
solutions mais il faut des fois des
solutions
voilà donc c'est la meilleure ça serait
la meilleure façon c'est de plus court
pas trop pas trop d'argent non plus si
vous demandez 500 millions de dollars ça
se peut que le ministre des Finances
vous le disent il a déjà dit dans les
rencontres à quelqu'un vous en demander
trop ok comment ça fonctionne la
préparation du budget on a l'impression
que c'est un procédé qui est très
intensif depuis quelques semaines vous
avez évoqué un mois ou deux est-ce qu'il
y a des des fonctionnaires au ministères
des Finances qui travaillent là-dessus
carrément toute l'année parce qu'il faut
corriger constamment de l'information
comment ça fonctionne mais le gros du
travail c'est de janvier à mars jusqu'au
dépôt évidemment il y a une équipe qui
suit l'évolution du budget tout au cours
de l'année mais à jour un peu les
prévisions et un budgétaire économique
mais le gros du travail sera le janvier
à mars puis ça commence à consultation
pré budgétaire il y a deux rencontres
avec le Premier ministre qui sont très
importants que la première s'adresse les
plus grands enjeux qui doivent être
mis dans le budget la deuxième sur
s'assurer que tout est en ordre qu'il y
a pas de surprise et puis après ça c'est
le ministre des Finances
au cabinet
aussi pour les ministres mais après les
décisions se font beaucoup ministères et
finances évidemment avec l'équipe du
Premier ministre le budget ou un budget
en général c'est des centaines de pages
monsieur goujon est-ce que le ministre
des Finances regarde connaît approuve
chacune des pages oui je lui ai son
équipe on lit tout tout
disons je les lis pas j'ai pas lu cette
année mais c'est au moins deux fois le
budget au complet parce que pour pas
avoir de mauvaise surprise pour
s'assurer que les messages sont bons
pour s'assurer que les modifications
pour qu'on a demandé on est intégré
c'est un gros travail quand même qui se
fait à l'intérieur de deux semaines mais
oui il est tout puis la section A il y a
même plus que deux fois d'accord donc
c'est la section qu'on doit regarder
attentivement dans le budget la section
A
pour rejoindre les les deux c'est
d'essuyer le sport ou des lames de
patins québécois et ça permet d'avoir
ça la semaine prochaine et le budget
surtout merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ça
fait plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]